move over lacey chabert take a seat
danica mckellar it's okay
you two reigning sovereigns of christmas
movies can take a well-deserved break
because there is a new queen in town and
her name is vanessa hudgins
get out while some might still see
hudgens as the girl who danced and sang
her way into our hearts via high school
musical
our girl has been putting in the work in
order to cement herself as the new
matriarch of the christmas movie genre
and today we want to figure out just how
she holly
jollied her way onto the throne
like many stars who got their start in
the world of disney after her turn as
gabriella montez in the high school
musical movies was over
vanessa hudgins set out to prove to the
world that she could not only just sing
and dance
but she could really act as well she
took it upon herself to pick roles that
were the complete
opposite of her glossy disney persona in
films like the controversial spring
breakers
sucker punch and gimme shelter and while
she definitely succeeded in showing off
her full range of talents
there is no denying that vanessa hudgins
does sweet better than just about anyone
else
i love what i do and i get to do it all
the time
so when she appeared in the princess
switch in 2018
it was truly a christmas miracle and in
the years since
the vanessa hudgens christmas movies
have kept on coming
in the first hudgins plays a young baker
named stacy
who was entered into a baking
competition in the fictional country of
belgravia
there she has a chance encounter with
the princess of belgravia named margaret
who happens to look exactly like stacy
because they're both played by vanessa
hudgens stacy denovo i think we were
destined to run into each other
one year after the princess switch
premiered on netflix we were awarded
with another hudgens christmas classic
titled the night before christmas in
which she plays a young teacher who
falls in love with a time traveling
medieval night
and now finally in 2020 netflix released
the princess switch switched again
the sequel to the original princess
switch but this time we get not one
not two but three vanessa hudgins's
not only does hudgens reprise her roles
as stacy and princess margaret but this
time she dons a blonde wig
in order to play margaret's evil cousin
lady fiona
oh it's such a pain to find good help
these days and in case you're wondering
if the movies ever give some sort of
reason as to why all these three women
look completely identical
maybe because they were separated at
birth in some kind of parent trap
situation
well they don't these are just three
vaguely related
or not related at all women who just
happen to look exactly the same
while many actors and actresses who have
come before have made their fair share
of christmas movies
we can't think of any others who have
starred opposite two different versions
of themselves
it really is an iconic movie if you
think about it and for that reason we
have to recognize vanessa hudgens as the
queen of the christmas movie that she is
this should be interesting let's go
we're thrilled that while she definitely
still chooses interesting and
challenging projects during the time
when she isn't princess switching and
switching again hudgin seems to have
totally embraced her destiny as the
reigning queen of the holiday season
but what exactly makes the princess
switch such an instant classic holiday
movie
there are thousands and thousands of
these hallmark style films out there
and they do tend to follow a pretty
similar trajectory a young woman who is
either a baker
school teacher or a writer stylist for
fashion magazine
is looking to fall in love in all the
wrong places true love
is always a worthy wish she winds up
taking a trip back to her hometown
a trip to a foreign land or a literal
trip into the arms of an unexpected yet
exceedingly handsome stranger who will
eventually teach her the importance of
christmas
and perfectly groomed five o'clock
shadow and it's not like the princess
switch is the first christmas movie with
a royal theme either
the much beloved christmas prince series
is definitely the most famous example of
an ordinary woman who falls in love with
an
out of her league royal even if all of
his royal family members disapprove
and yet the princess switch and its
sequel really stand out among all of
them
whether that is because netflix has
simply perfected the christmas movie
formula
giving us all of the classic holiday
rom-com elements that we want
while adding in a layer of humor and
excitement by having a big star like
vanessa hudgens play multiple versions
of herself
the princess switch knows that it's
there to make us smile and laugh
and feel a little warmer during the cold
winter months and it delivers on all
fronts
but something we only just discovered
might just make the princess switch and
all of the other netflix christmas
movies
even more important than we thought they
are all connected
that's right it can now be proven that
nine of the best christmas movies on
netflix including the princess switch
all take place in the same universe it
goes back to 2018's the holiday calendar
in which a clip from the 2017 movie the
christmas inheritance can be seen
playing on tv
it also pops up once again on tv in the
first princess switch movie
in another little cameo netflix holiday
in the wild
can be seen playing on screen during the
second vanessa hudgens christmas movie
the night before christmas
but here's where things get really
interesting in the first princess switch
we see margaret and kevin watching the
beloved a christmas prince movie on tv
yet in switched again during margaret's
coronation scene amber and richard the
main characters in a christmas prince
are actually in attendance at the event
which can only mean one thing
in the world of the princess switch a
christmas prince is actually a
documentary about amber and richard
and we're not even done yet in 2018's
the night before christmas
vanessa hudgen's older sister tells her
daughter that her grandparents brought
back a giant decorative acorn from a
trip to aldovia
the fictional country in which a
christmas prince takes place
and then in a christmas prince the royal
baby
a map is shown which lists belgravia the
other fictional country where
the action of the princess switch is set
as a neighboring country to aldovia
phew is anyone else tired all of a
sudden if you need a visual for how all
of these films tie into one another
netflix themselves release this helpful
infographic so
not only do we know that the princess
switch and a christmas prince are taking
place just across a border from one
another
and that the royal families actually
know each other but that somehow the
night before christmas
is also in the same world even though
both belgravia and aldovia are fictional
and is set in the very real ohio what
does it all mean
we have to wonder just why netflix would
have gone through all of the trouble of
connecting these films to one another in
such obvious ways
they had to have known that fans would
spot the cameos and figure the whole
thing out
so what exactly are they planning it
makes sense that belgravia and aldovia
could exist in the same world
but why did they sneak in that reference
to aldovia in the night before christmas
we don't concern ourselves with the
details we have people for that
of course of course while we don't know
for sure
we have one theory brooke and her time
traveling knight
are eventually going to make their way
into the princess switch
we already have three vanessa hudgens's
it's not out of the realm of possibility
that we could soon have a fourth
and hey they have already introduced
time travel so would a plane ride to
belgravia really be all that difficult
modern technology is lit
a f and who's to say they'll stop there
we have a feeling that netflix is just
getting started with the expansion of
their christmas movie cinematic universe
following in the footsteps of marvel and
the avengers we can picture a future in
which all of the characters from the
night before christmas
the princess switch and a christmas
prince all come together in one
massive avengers endgame style spectacle
only there will be less war
and a lot more mistaken identity hijinks
and happy endings
we hope and if all of that winds up
happening it will mean a million more
opportunities for vanessa hudgins to
take on as
many different characters as she
possibly can we know netflix has the
budget for all of the wigs needed to
make
it work we absolutely hope that one day
in the future
we are gifted a movie called the
princess switch the switching
in which vanessa hudgins plays every
single character including the four that
she already has created
and maybe one day they'll try to explain
just why all of these women have the
exact same face
we cannot wait to see how netflix
continues to tie these three films
together
over the holidays for years to come and
we have no doubt that the reigning queen
of christmas miss vanessa hudgins will
be at the center of it all
now that we have established that
vanessa hudgins is without a doubt the
absolute queen of the christmas season
we can only hope that her reign is long
and prosperous
what about you do you love the netflix
christmas universe as much as we do
or do you think that a different star
should sit on the throne let us know in
the comments
and don't forget to hit that subscribe
button to keep up with all the latest
videos from the things